okay we're now live
okay thank you alex okay can i welcome
everybody to
tonight's meeting of the licensing
subcommittee
for tuesday the 20th of april
um the attendance list uh is
is on the is on the screen so uh alex
you can take the names from that
do do we have any apologies from natalie
no other apologies have been received
okay so the only item of the night is
the application for the grant of a new
premises license
under section 17 of the licensing act
2003
at totties because away altering them
okay so i'll just do we'll just do some
introductions so we have we have mr dodd
the applicant
hi there evening hello okay
welcome to the meeting uh my name is
councillor david jarman i'm chairing
this
uh this panel and i i also have
councillors but
and thomas who make up the panel um
we have from the office as a legal
officer a licensing officer and a
democratic services officer
so can i ask if people could keep
themselves on mute until they
they wish to speak or they're called to
speak um
and then obviously to make sure they
take themselves off from you
so it's a bit of juggling sometimes
takes a bit
a bit to get used to it but um i'm sure
i'm sure we'll get there
okay um can i ask mr hinchcliffe the
licensing officer to
to outline the application please
mr um thank you
under section 18 4
of the license that 2003 members are
requested to determine an application
for a new premises license
in respect of torti's causeway
alternating
having regard to the representations
received and the requirement to promote
the four licensing objectives
the following options are open to the
licensing subcommittee
you can grant the application in full
from the terms and conditions contained
within that application
to include any applicable mandatory
conditions you can grant the application
as above but modified to such an extent
as considered appropriate to satisfy any
relevant representations and promote the
licensing objectives
or you can reject the application a
premises license is required
in respect of any premises where it's
intended to conduct one or more of the
four licensed activities
this application was submitted by
jonathan dodd in respect of totties
the applicants applied for the following
hours
you see recorded music um dance
late night refreshment um sale of
alcohol on the premises
and uh and the opening hours all match
monday to sunday
from 8 p.m to 3 a.m the application was
properly made
when all the procedures were correctly
followed the application including the
amended operating schedule
has been attached as appendix a and the
photographs of the blue notice in place
and a copy of the newspaper advert for a
taxes depended to be
in terms of the background and history
of the premises the premises was
has been previously licensed but this
this laps due to the death of the
license holder
and the license has been attached as
appendix c
the applicant has described the premises
as a well-established club
in the center of altering him it's been
operating for 15 plus years his father
who is the previous premises licensed
holder
has passed away so he's applying for a
new one in line with the council policy
the club is situated on the second floor
with access via the causeway
and there is a bar at the back of the
club with roughly seating for 50
customers
the club also includes a dance section
with a pole strictly for the use of
employees only
there is an emergency exit at the back
of the club supply room
an office and a staff room the operating
schedule
that's completed by the applicant and it
contains the additional measures to
illustrate
how they'll propose to promote the four
licensing objectives
that's required by the provisional
license act 2003
they've been listed below in your report
and they will be attached as conditions
to any license as may be granted
you can see that they're related cctv
and no noise checked facilities around
anti-bottle storage and no external
speakers
the consultation the responsible
authorities including a consultation
greater manchester bleak
fire and rescue environmental health and
pollution control
we also have building control health and
safety team
immigration enforcement planning
departments and the safeguarding
children's team
and finally we have training standards
and public health of those console tees
identified in paragraph 4.1
no representations were received we have
however
two representations from other persons
who are two local residents
which we've received in respect of noise
pollution they're both attached as
appendix d
a copy of this report and
representations receives has been sent
to the applicant
and those have been uh made
representation of invited
to attend the hearing
finally chair your legal considerations
conditions may only be attached to a
premises license if you're familiar with
this book
for the benefit everyone conditions may
only be attached to the premises license
where they are deemed appropriate for
the promotion of licensing objectives
it must be proportionate we must not
duplicate any existing provisions
contained in other legislation
a justification behind the refusal or
the attachment of conditions
must be given to the applicant um
in arriving at the decision the
subcommittee must have regards to the
relevant provisions of national guidance
its own statement of licensing policy
and any reason
should be given for any departures of
this there is a right of appeals to the
magistrates court within 21 days from
the daily applicant
is notified of the decision of the
licensing subcommittee
um i'm happy to take any any questions
chair but
that that concludes uh the report for
the one mata this evening
okay thank you mr hinchcliffe um yeah
i've got a couple of questions
um how's uh the has the club been
been on covered lockdown since uh
the end of march last year or probably
at all in that period
uh yeah the um
they would have been impacted by the by
the kobe closures at that point yeah
obviously plus as a club so they
wouldn't have been yeah
right so they're still
so sorry they'll still remain remain
closed until
um later on this year i think as well
yeah okay we can ask the applicant when
he intends to open
um now they've been open 15 years um
now previously we've not had many
objections but
i suppose they could all all be clusters
like moral
objections if you like um uh
is it correct that we've had i think i
read somewhere in the port we've had no
complaints about
about its operation and so so we we've
got we have two
um separate licenses for for that club
so every single year
we um we have the sex establishment
venue license
and so every single year we will consult
consult on that on that application so
um
when you're talking about the the moral
objections that we sometimes hear
that's quite often but um a consequence
of
the uh the sex establishment license
that we go out to a consultation on on
on each year for the um for the actual
premises license
this would have been um granted
originally
and then and there wouldn't have been
any consultation
throughout that process so effectively
it was issued and
and throughout that period it just
maintains there's no
there's no consultation um during the
scope of that time for any complaints
associated to the property
they're made to they can be made to
greater manchester police or to a local
authority
and but we haven't been supplied with um
any representation from um those
responsible authorities so
we we don't have that as as evidence for
the report
that this evening okay thank you mr
hinchcliffe
um can i ask if there are any if the
other members of the panel we should
wish to
uh ask a question mr hinchcliffe
could i just um build on that last thing
i just put a question in the chat box
but i was just wanting to know so so the
initial premises license was only
granted like when
the when the company started when
totty's opened initially and it's never
been
um looked at since that period
essentially
so yep so
for any um um
i think that that's come from one of one
of the uh representations
is that mr ingram that's correct yeah
okay explosion um so
for any premises license that's issued
under the
um lao three accident the license now
2003
the the license will be applied for and
issued
um and the license will uh
exist in its in in
indefinitely i'm unless that license is
brought to review so any person
um you know any any person in terms of
it doesn't have to be a responsible
authority that brings a review
any uh the term is other person
so um any person can bring an
application through
for a review of a license um and we
we do see um applications for reviews of
licenses applications for
expedited reviews of licenses are quite
often submitted by
greater manchester police if there's
been significant crime
that warrants the um the promises being
suspended or
or revoked um so we've not had
um any any summary reviews or we've not
had any
applications for a standard review so
um so in terms of the actual journey of
that license
it was issued and it's remained in that
status quo um throughout its
throughout its period yeah and even even
just
um so just to be clear then so when so
when that event happened in 2017
uh related to the the death of the
individual outside the club
yeah that was not then referred to this
licensing
as a licensing committee you know that
wasn't it no it wasn't
it wasn't it wasn't referred to the
licensing committee now
um so you it has to be triggered by uh
by a responsible authority to um to
bring a license for
review so um i i don't believe that
um there is there's been any um
there's any any hearing for the premises
i think
yeah i think it was it was um
it was renewed on the 25th of june last
year
as a renewable uh obviously it was
mr dodd's father in that in that case
um yeah because i actually remember
sitting on that committee i wasn't
chairing it
but it was it was renewed then there was
there was uh one objection which you
could come under the umbrella of a moral
objection but it was it was renewed on
the 25th of june
sorry that's um that that that's so
there's there's
there's there's there's two separate
authorizations
um so what you would have what you would
have sat on on it
as part of um as the uh
the chair of the licensing um committee
you would have sat on the application
for the
um sexual entertainment venue license
absolutely and every single year
that will call before the committee for
forever more
um but for the fit for just what we're
discussing this evening which is the
alcohol it's the alcohol license
and the license for um the regulated
entertainment in the form of
music itself so um if you think
this is there's two licenses that exist
one is for the sexual entertainment
and the other element which is the
license for the sale of alcohol
and for um for the night club elements
which would be um the the noise and the
the dancing to do with a nightclub
rather than
um rather than the the
the entertainment provisions on the
alternative act so
um that that's that that's the there's
two parallel licenses there
is that does that make sense yeah yeah
thanks for saying good luck
clears it up um can i answer the other
panel members if we have a question
yes sir can i just come in on that one
uh just following on from what's just
been said
uh i would assume that um
something might have been said or
reviewed
had there been any implication against
the club itself
that uh would have been involved in that
case
i i take it that uh perhaps something
was
said because it wasn't actually the
club's responsibility or it wasn't
because of the
directive involvement of the club
we were i think we would we would be on
fairgrounds to
um um to to
to contact conclusion yeah because with
the absent a bit of a bit of a hearing
trigger you would you would um
you would you would have to come to that
conclusion i think i i mentioned that
because
uh i think some years back there was a
death outside the
what was before nicholson's on the
corner you know on the downs at the
bottom
uh but the the pub nicholson's
which is no longer a pub anymore but
it's it it wasn't
uh closed or like license revoked for
that reason
yeah if something happens i i i don't
i don't believe that the um
the incident that happened was was was
related to the club now i wasn't
employed with trafford at that time
but i have had these conferences i
suppose this is the way that this this
is evidence but i think it's it's it's
fair
to say in terms of what you're asking um
i don't believe that the um police
considered the
incident that happened
the death that occurred was related to
the
totty's premises itself and um
if it would have been uh related to
totties then
the expectation would um would would
more be on par
with and with it with a either a summary
review
where we um where we remove the
the actual license itself uh or we
handle a premises
license um hearing by way of application
and both those things that did not occur
so
i think we we stand on on the right
ground to say that
um that they were in related matters
okay thank you
okay thank you because if i could please
dad
yeah of course okay karen on the
operating schedule on page three
um point one uh he says the door staff
will operate like the club only on
weekends
and when we expect it to be busy due to
other circumstances
and we will ensure safety and that only
customers of the 18 are allowed access
yet in the annex 2 on page 50
0.2 is the door security provision shall
be extended to match the
licensed hours so
can you just click will be door security
on whilst it's open
or just the weekends in in terms of the
license
um i think your your you're you're
pointing out a
potential contradiction in terms of
what's been proposed with those two
operating schedules and one's been
amended
it'd be it'd be right for uh for the
applicant to address that contradiction
rather than myself so that's fine okay
no problem yeah i did mention
i think i didn't mention that when i put
forward that point and initially i think
it got brought back to me
um the club usually during the week we
are pretty quiet
sort of eight to ten customers uh that's
tuesday wednesday um
thursday again is depending on kind of
what time of the year it is
as we approach christmas months we sort
of become a bit busier we kind of gauge
that over a couple of weeks whether we
need
door stuff or not and then every weekend
without fail we
we do have door stuff on um special
events sort of
uh football related um any bank holidays
if we uh anything like that that sort of
thing if there's any special occasions
um just that kind of sort of thing in
general really
okay thank you okay mr dos thanks for
clearing that up
so if there's no more questions for the
license
licensing officer i'll um i'll move to
mr dob
the applicant to to outline uh just to
speak in support of his application
um so i've been managing the uh the
business myself for the last two years
um in essence all that has happened
obviously we've not had a review of the
premises license in over 15 years
um as none of the authorities have
deemed it necessary
um the only reason i've had to review
the license because the pastor my father
who was did the day-to-days of the
business uh
effectively nothing is changing at all
in terms of what the day-to-day running
and the responsibility of that during
the day would you just lie on me
um just a couple more things that i'd
have to do in terms of the management of
the business my father wasn't involved
in that it was purely me so
it is just sort of um the policy
originally i actually thought that i
could just get it changed over without
the premises license having to be
renewed
um which is what uh jane from licensing
also thought originally
uh but then it just came to our
attention that i'd have to just go
through this process
and here we are
is that all you'd like to say
yeah in terms of what's happening with
the business that's what i'd like to say
in terms of the actual objections
themselves
obviously the flats are very new to
opening up outside the club
and i've seen issues about parking and
the objections when
it's a loading beta as well as disabled
parking
uh litter the whole area is at loading
bay and i think that would be unfair to
pin it on the club
um we have a cleaner who comes in uh pre
usually around six a.m every morning
make sure that any litter
is outside the club is tidied up and
other situations such as noise i know
one of the objections
i've noticed the noise changed after
we've been there for two weeks
we've not had an issue with noise in 15
years um
fighting illicit drugs uh all these
claims that have been made
we haven't had any objections from the
police in terms of this we have a good
relationship with the police
and karen pakka i've spoke to is our
representative there
and she's happy with the way this club's
been established
and and ran kind of previously and has
no reservations about what was going
forward in that respect
that's everything i'd like to say okay
thank you mr dodd so um so you
you were previously the manager now now
you you want to take over the
licensing since the death of your father
should i say
first of all many condolences on your
father's passing
thank you um so you now want to take
over
want to take over the license when is it
you
you intend to open uh 21st of june is
what's been speculated for when clubs
are allowed to open
um that's the monday so our first uh
open day would probably be the 22nd of
june
as we open tuesday through saturday
right okay um so you previously were the
manager of the club how long
how long were you were you managing the
club
uh probably about a year and a half
before
um lockdown and then i uh
will continue to be the manager there uh
ongoing
right were you were you're aware of any
issues
any complaints from residents albeit
the um well
comparatively new could you point it out
yeah well i think it's understandable um
to move in across a place
uh the place uh from the business and
then have complaints about it
and because ideally you wouldn't want it
there however i would
uh say that we've been there for 15 plus
years and
uh you should have had reservations
about moving in there
to just to expect um
uh general uh sort of
um use of a late night bar that that
happens there
in terms of taxis um if there's a
noise outside uh minimal levels of noise
but noise outside in general
and i just think it's sought to be
expected and
and for example if you use the analogy
of
moving on the road of a school or next
to a football ground i think it should
sort of fall into the same category as
that
uh right so
into well in terms of the door stuff you
said that there are
the only they're only on at weekends or
when when you require them to be on
because yes
you say like a football match so what
what
what what is their brief in terms of
dealing with
your customers that are outside the
premises
no drinks are allowed to be taken
outside the premises
um so it's purely people that go outside
there for smoking
and we have uh fins that have been
we have the cleaner comes in and make
sure that any cigarette butts are taken
away
um the door staff wants to encourage
people to disperse
before instead of hanging around outside
the club that sort of thing
and yeah
right so to what to they they actually
finish their shift when the club
finishes it is it 3am isn't it
yes yeah the door staff the door stuff
come on about 10 a.m until 3am
as i said genuinely we're not a busy
club and we are quite quiet
and then uh we do get a late a bit of a
late night rush um
because it is one of the latest places
out in altringham
um which is when the door stuff is
mainly required for from the
from the period of sort of twelve till
three a.m
and on ongoing we pay them uh longer to
they obviously get rid of customers uh
ask them to leave sort of half too and
then people disperse from there on
and then the door staff will be there
until everyone has left and
people are leaving from outside the
venue as well
so so they'll be there till everybody's
dispersed from outside
yes generally right and you you have
cctv that
that covers the outside area yes we've
got two cameras one that uh directly
covers the door
um from outside that is visible as well
as a sign
which um says smile you're on camera to
make everyone aware that they're on on
camera there and then there's another
wider plan camera which is just on the
left of the door which overview is a bit
more of the site
uh there are two cameras that we have
outside the front of the premises
could i just ask a question based around
that um is that okay
is the and just as well whilst you're on
sorry condolences also
and this isn't a personal thing but i
just wanted to
you know this is just me coming as a
resident it's not me against your
business or anything
so um i just wondered if the door on
george street is that not in operation
at all
so originally the club was on george
street
and that's how it was operated until um
i'm not sure what happened in the past
but
um we were required to take down the
signage from george street
and that's why we have the main entrance
now in the causeway
um and then we just use that as a fire
exit okay
cool but there's no cameras from your
business on that side even if
because it's a fire exit and there's
other cameras around that region
um well we don't we don't use that exit
is purely a fire exit there's never any
customers out of there and the only time
we'd ever use that for a customer is
we're dispersing
any issues we have inside of the club
and where we
take one group of members outside the
back and one out the front sort of thing
that's the only time it's ever been used
since i've been there
and then and in that instance that
wouldn't be caught on camera
correct okay cool thank you hammers in
every area of the club we don't have a
camera onto
onto george street well mr dodd is yours
is a cctv camera in operation 24
7. correct yeah
about three months right and and
you said you mentioned the cleaner that
so the cleaner comes on every
you're open every day no open tuesday
through saturday we've just always had
the like the option to open on uh on
every day
as well um we have trailed running on a
sunday before
um however due to the lack of customers
we have uh close that down
on the odd bank holiday uh we tried
opening as well
um but usually we can't find the stuff
or
a very limited number one holiday so it
doesn't tend to be too profitable for us
and the initial um kind of plans are to
just continue operating tuesday through
saturday as we have been doing
um however however the in the
applications or i know we already always
had the premises license
uh in that matter before but we just
haven't used them in particular days
so every day you're in operation the
cleaner comes on at six in the morning
and cleans in the vicinity around
the club is that correct
right so all that all that area is
cleaned at six a.m
the two yeah so tuesday we open tuesday
night and then wednesday morning
as she'll come um and then
[Music]
wednesday thursday friday saturday and
then sunday as well
right i'll just ask you something
well for accuracy really because it's
included in
in your application
you put under the section k adult
entertainment
or services the activities of totties
include topless
non-contact dancing in communal private
rooms away from the main
floor can you show me on the plan where
those rooms are
uh yeah um i'm not sure about having to
hand if
you're looking at the plan page 37
of the um report
if you're looking at the plan so you're
looking at where the bar is
yeah yeah so you can keep where the bar
goes there yeah uh it's on if you're
stood behind the bar looking forward
towards the opening of the club
then brooms are on the left they're not
private uh route
it's a private communal room it's a they
have like cowboy doors
um leading into him one of the rooms is
completely
there is no door the other one has
cowboy door so it's
quite visible so it's the area on the
left here
correct yeah not all that area just the
top bit and and
a bit on the right so they're not
completely closed though
is that correct yeah that's right
they're not they're not closed off it's
not it's not
a one-on-one private it's the same room
that all the dancers use there
right so presumably that's for security
because obviously you
you don't want a customer in a close
room with uh
one of one of your performers obviously
without
some visibility if
there's more than one customer in there
more than one dancer in there
and then we've found over the years that
you don't
usually have any issues and that's just
the way we've always operated
okay can i ask
any of the other panel members if you
have any questions for the applicant
it's just a quick one can you just
confirm how long you keep the recordings
floor on the
cameras please gentlemen um i wouldn't
be able to completely confirm it but i'm
pretty sure it's sort of
the three month mark and it is a very
up-to-date uh
camera system that we do have there
which has been used by the police a
couple of times for
different things we have it running
completely throughout the day it has a
three-month
kind of backup so it runs 24 hours and
then we can kind of go back and
and pick uh different things that we've
had examples of
customers stealing trying to steal one
of the girls bags a
customer thinking that someone else has
taken a chain and
it's very up today and resolved any
issues that we sort of had in the past
so it meets the pixels and obviously
your dvr is a
there's a good quality one with
obviously plenty of space on it okay
thank you
okay thank you does anybody else have
any questions for the applicant
does that include the people with the
objection yeah
yeah is this so this would be the point
where we raise what we want to
why we're objecting just questions to
the applicant you'll get a chance to
make any statements or
put your case afterwards it's just
questions on basically
his application of what what he said
at this stage okay
okay
or do you just want to go into to making
a statement without
i mean um i don't know if i don't know
if the other if
abby had any specific questions as well
was was it abby who was the other person
who's
objecting i i i'm happy to just
make a statement and then if um jonathan
wants to reply to it or whatever i do
and whatever you like i don't mind i'll
ask abby if she's got any questions for
the applicant of this day
thank you no no no no questions oh my
gosh
okay thank you abby okay
mr burton would you like to make a
statement
of how you see the establishment
and how it's run well my
my biggest concerns i mean um as mr dodd
said
i mean you do it there's certain sorts
of compromises that you make when you
choose to live in an
uh apartment right in the middle of a
town centre and
noise is it's one of them and you sort
of choose that that's
you know accepted then it's a valid
point that you know i chose to buy an
apartment that was opposite
a a late night venue but my argument is
well my point is is that the makeup of
the causeway area has changed quite a
lot in the last
time since toshi's was last able to
operate
my building the apartment i live in
there's nine apartments
we were when at the beginning of mar i
moved at the beginning of march last
year there was only three people
the other residents living here at that
time so you won't have had many
complaints because there simply wasn't
the residence to complain
we've only been living here the
building's only been full really since
the summer of last year and i'm aware
that there are other apartments
obviously uh rob must live somewhere
along here as well
and you know these new residents need to
be taken into consideration
you know i appreciate as well that
copies aren't responsible for the
behavior of their customers when they're
not inside
the premises but these people are only
going to be on the causeway
because they're coming to or from
totties there's no other reason at 2am
in the morning where anybody else would
be
in that area so to me that doesn't mean
that totties do have a level of
responsibility
to make sure that the customers are
well behaving themselves and in my the
two weeks that i didn't experience
totti's being open and spared at the
weekend
it was awful it was just horrendous
i mean far worse than that you know it's
a few junk and drunk and sort of words
every now and then you know
again you live with it but it was
fighting shouting somebody urinated at
the side of my car
which is also parked out the back the
car apart from my um
apartment is out the back on facing onto
the causeway
you know and at the end of the day a
chap whether it's related to totties or
not
was involved in an incident which result
resulted in his death
in that area and i don't know whether he
was in totti's or not that evening i
don't know and i know it's not totti's
fault that he got into a fight but
that's the kind of behavior
that concerns me gravely and now that
you have residents living in that area
i just i'm not i haven't got a problem
with totties there's a lot dancing bar
you you'd be what you want but you have
to have a
there's a responsibility towards the
residents that now live in that area
is what i would like to say
can i just would i be able to build on
that with mine or do you want to let
jonathan reply
miss burn some questions really
so um miss burton do you live in that
new development
straight opposite the club on the
causeway
yeah so it's actually the address is
stanford new road but yes it's it's the
back of the apartment
the forecast it's like a courtyard isn't
it yes
yeah yeah is that the only residential
development on the courtyard
in that courtyard specifically i believe
so but i think there
are other apartments further along still
on the
actual causeway but further along going
to my left i suppose yeah but when you
said courtyard did you mean
courtyard specifically rather than the
causeway because there are numerous
apartments i'll
ask you in a minute mr ingram that's
okay sorry i
i'll ask you apologize that's okay um
you're referring to the courtyard is in
the area
i'm not quite sure what the thoughts
were it's called the causeway it's
basically
um a road around with an island
my apartment is there my car park is
just off that island
basically and the rear entrance to my
building is is off the causeway yes
so so what you witnessed happened at
those two weekends leading up to
the lockdown on both weekends
both weekends it was just you know
especially on friday and saturday night
until
i don't even know i gave up looking
after three o'clock in the morning at
what time it was but it was
just it was constant constant noise
after about midnight i would say between
midnight and probably half past three
four o'clock in the morning
constant noise constant shouting
sounded like some fights um
i didn't want to i didn't want to sort
of get involved because it was very
it's very intimidating for residents to
have to deal with that
literally on their doorstep um it's not
particularly pleasant
right how sure could you be that these
were customers of totties that were
involved in this
well i can't be and as i said i do i
know totties are not responsible
per se for the response for the behavior
of their customers but there's nothing
else
really there's nowhere else that i know
of in ultranam
that is open until that till that time
i can't there's nothing else here
there's the pub on the other side
on george street but that's not open at
three o'clock in the morning
so i don't know where these people would
have been coming from if they hadn't
been going
bars coming at the top of austrian near
the market
sort of concluding not at three o'clock
in the morning at
two there's a walking path from there to
goose green
there's another load of bars and so
understandably that probably a lot of
the footfall that comes
directly through there it can be through
to me but from
the top of altering them where there's
the cellar and the bars on the
right-hand side there
and goose green which is another popular
area uh
the cutwork the cut path through there
is a
very uh people what can do there all the
time you've got pierre bistro on the
right hand side as well
it is quite popular footpath throughout
the evening
and i would just like to say that so it
is it a cut through or is it is it an
enclosed
sort of arena
there's two different alleyways there's
one sort of directly in front of the
club a bit to the right
and then further down the causeway the
other end there's another cut through
which is sort of
near ravuna and subway
right so what you could what you're
saying it's possible that somebody could
be just passing through there
don't get me wrong uh customers that are
directly outside the club who
may have been in the club but it is also
a popular cut path from the top of ultra
gym to the bottom of ultrasound
to through to the two different sort of
groups of and areas of bars
within them locations you've got kings
court
goose green at the bottom end and then
you've got the markets the conclude
[Music]
the whole range of bars at the top and
anyone i know people my age
throughout the evening back and forth
can i just ask
kieran the licensing officer do we have
any
comparison about closing times with with
other establishments in order and town
center
um we can uh i can
i can pull out what we have available
for for good screen
um few screens probably the the latest
area which
um logistically is is is is very close
and i i i would be confident that there
is potentially some overlap
i'd just like to point out um
to yourself chair um as part of the
statement of life
the statement of licensing policy for
the council
because um there's been some comments in
terms of
um where this license sits and
where the responsibility lies with uh
with the license holder and
and that that external area so um
to offer a bit of clarity in terms of
the scope and i don't
you know as yourself you're obviously
accustomed to this but just
for the purposes of transparency for the
objectives and
uh and the applicant at 32.5
of the statement of license improv
policy it says that all premises
applying for licensing beyond midnight
must demonstrate that is that its
customers will be capable of leaving
the area without causing a disruption to
local residents
or impact upon crime disorder for
example where appropriate
and relevant an assessment of the
availability of late-night transport
and the likely flow of pedestrian
traffic away from the premises
and that could be included in the
operating schedule what you have in the
operating schedule
from the applicant is um
is is detail on
signage for people of the customers
leaving the area
uh we've got some description on the
cctv
and then we've got the elements of the
door staff and the operating schedule
does
mention about encouraging customers to
uh to leave the area uh in a quiet and
orderly manner so
um those are the the the some of the
you know the key points that need to be
put out there in terms of your
your question to me chair um do you want
me to
bring together some of the um some of
the hours for
for the goose screen area so you've got
that to hand
if that would be helpful okay and if you
could
i'll i'll dig that out this is relative
obviously it's just a comparison really
i mean i
imagine it's the latest in orchargum
town center at three o'clock but
just good comparison i had i think tiki
bars
3am at the latest there and then you've
got um what was coco's lounge is now
roy's sports bar on the corner it's 2
a.m
um and that's every night and then and i
think seller it could be 2 am as well
and some of the bars around there
sellers
um when you witnessed what you witnessed
well the club was the club was still
open
for most of the time was it yeah
well the club was open for two when i
moved into this property at the
beginning of march the club was open
for two well over two weekends in the
week it didn't
didn't really make any difference to be
perfectly honest it was more
on a friday and saturday night so it was
two weekends
leading up to the lock down when when
nightclubs and bars had to shut yeah
i like said they did we only this
building was only finished
really in a sort of inhabitable purpose
in sort of january of last year
so people have only been living here for
sort of six months really
um i was one of the first people to move
in and that was in march and
when there was only two other residents
living here when i moved in
okay so from what from your window where
you witnessed the club and
the activities outside were the door
staff visible
all right okay thank you does anybody uh
have any questions for ms burton please
just uh quickly so just so uh you're
aware
so the door staff are located two of
them that we have on always at a time
they're located in general houses like
the little box and then it leads up the
stairs
so
is located downstairs as well i'm gonna
have
one tv there and then i kind of asked
the door staff to
sporadically uh take walks across the
uh like up and down the club but we have
um
a system on the door where to you access
the club
uh on weekends it's right because the
store stuff are there but on midweek so
they'll have to buzz in
uh to make to get in as it would keep it
pretty
like as a private club and they said
we're not that busy and i don't have
door stuff on weekends
and so that's how it's run that the door
staff are always downstairs
they're usually kind of stood outside if
they're having a smoke or
chatting to the customers there and
in light of it becoming a much more
residential area as you guys are saying
um obviously we'll make the utmost kind
of attention to
the door staff to keep it as quiet as
possible um throughout these evenings
and obviously with the cctv
and put an increased kind of um uh
strangulation on on that that is what
isn't
needed and expected of the customers
that are coming into and leaving the
the venue alongside those that are
smoking outside uh whilst they are there
thank you thank you mr john um
okay mr ingram oh yeah
it's your chance now to to sort of make
your statement
cool okay thank you so um i've been
living here four years
i live in um apartment
um well sorry in the apartments at the
end 1a the causeway
um so actually three and a half years
four years in august to be precise
so um as
abby kind of raised fridays and
saturdays
um are very very very loud and they
again
agree we live in we live in the town
center and we're aware
of the nature of that however i think
the points that have been made around
the fact that
there is especially that last hour at
least where totties is open between 2
and 3 a.m where
the people unless they've just been
hanging around in town
which in cold winter in altering them i
find
like unlikely fair enough maybe in the
summer
but um you know that is when it's that
sort of
the amount of times where i've been
woken up in the
like you know been fast asleep and then
just people screaming outside our flat
basically
um is i can't even count the number to
be frank
the reason why i've made this objection
now is simply because
and not before is because i wasn't aware
that i could just raise an objection it
was when i saw the notice
that this licensing has been remade so
that was this is why i've been prompted
to do it by that
and so it's not that i've been
fined for four years and everything's
great not at all
saturdays and fridays are really like a
blight on on my life to be frank but
anyway
um so i think the other thing to draw
attention to
is that you know the people who have
been in toys as soon as they
as soon as they get past the bouncers
and they're on the street
just because they've been told to be
quiet doesn't mean that they are going
to be quiet
like george street itself is an is a
basically like a wind tunnel that noise
carries everywhere
and for at least that last hour most of
the people who are out and about
around this proximity are people who
have been in parties and they go most
people as you say it's a late bar they
go there to stay out to extend their
evening to drink more alcohol
to lose their inhibitions more to be
louder like that's why people go out and
drink to have fun
and they don't care that people are
living there they don't give a crap
they're just going to do what they want
to do and you know that's
that's what they do because because
they're not being
sort of watched or anything as soon as
they're at those doors
like in 20 meters away they're going to
do what they want to do
and that's just what happens i think
what happened with me as well is is that
covid happened
and the lockdown happened and i was like
oh my god
what is this what it like you know it
became so
quiet and i know that's obviously all of
the bars combined and everything and
that's
fine it's not all of 20 customers but
especially
beyond 2am it is
in the main it's got to be who else is
it
the other things that i've encountered
because i have a dog sometimes he just
decides to wait he basically needs a pee
in the middle of the night and we don't
have a garden because we're in an
apartment i've walked out my wife's had
to take the dog out when i've not been
here
there's been people who've been going
into the club who have given her
you know said stuff to her and and she's
not felt safe and things like that to be
frank um
it's it is it is becoming more of a
residential area the
altering them has changed a lot and it
is changing and the causeway region
and the town if you look at the plan
that the council are doing
for for trying to bring new life into
the town center especially down the
other end of
george street as well they're planning
on bringing more residential properties
into that there has to be some give and
take with residents
right i'm pretty like it has affected my
life
quite a lot over these last four years
of living here
and i don't want it to continue and
that's why i'm raising an objection
because at the minute it just maybe the
police aren't objecting but the police
don't
live here
okay is that conclude
i mean i could talk for a while
i mean obviously the question for us is
is how much
of this can you can we attribute it to
totties and the customers or how much is
you know a general
i think like i'm saying in the area so
i think the specific there is
specifically things that happen
beyond 2am definitively and i don't
like i'm saying like in the winter who
is hanging around in alternate town
center
like between 2 and 3 a.m when it's
freezing this this happens year round
saturday
friday nights right just to be clear you
you live you say 1a the causeway
so we lift the other end of the other
end of the causeway and the turning
circle at the end
there's other residents here who i know
had problems as well and weren't
it seems they weren't invited someone
else another
another resident in advertisers i mean
it's whoever really sees the adverts
which is
posted locally and in the local press i
mean you can't we can't write to
everybody
no no um you know but at least we've got
a representation
of yourself and then miss burton here
so so your flat is above um
the main street on george street so all
of the over still
and we still hear people screaming and
shouting at the top of their voices
definitely past 2 a.m on a friday and
saturday night every single weekend
and like obviously this has not been
happening recently
like and even even since the pubs have
reopened and stuff outside now
we haven't had any noise like beyond 2am
on the weekend
okay so can you see the club from work
from your window
okay see the general area
i look i look on to so our our flats
our flats there are some flats that look
onto the causeway and then there are
some that look onto george street i look
on to george
and mine looks into george street
okay um can i ask you
the other issue i have as well i know
there's been talk about cleaners and
everything
but i have a i have a car which i pay
for a garage because our flats don't
have garages i bring the car down to my
flats
you know and there is so much broken
glass
around the area i've had numerous times
when i've had to
have punctures and stuff and have to buy
new tyres because
the cleaner might be cleaning glass
directly outside but they're again
i know it's hard to attribute but like
there is
an issue with people who who are
drinking outside and smashing glasses
somewhere and
i know you think your bouncers can see
everything and i know there's other
venues but there are people
why are they doing it down the course
way it seems strange to me that like
other people have carried their drinks
from a totally different venue all the
way down to the causeway and then
smashing glass
so yeah but is it a cut-through to go to
other venues
or is it just an enclosed area well it's
a cut through but my point is why would
someone carry
a glass right logic of this why would
they carry a glass specifically to the
causeway
and then drop it and smash it there
when there is a venue serving alcohol
serving the certificate that has glasses
bottles whatever
in the proximity yeah well
some of those may have been carried
there but there will be glasses that are
that have come from toys as well
okay take your point does anybody else
have any questions for mr england
yeah mr england
you can although you don't look onto the
causeway or you
you have a uh you you just
hear the noise from where you are yeah
which can you just indicate which shop
are you above
yeah so um we're around sort of like
where the cherish
and the salvation army around that sort
of area
there are no licensed properties between
totties and where my flat is in that
space
[Music]
uh yeah okay right
yeah uh i noticed i i do know that i
mean i think there's about three
entrances into the causeway isn't there
there's one through the tunnel one and
then you've got the one there the uh
the the wine the bistro place that's
opened near the mobility place
you mean the tapas restaurant there's
one subway the tapas restaurant
then there's one that's kind of opposite
toys and then there's obviously like the
car
and the vehicle a bit as well yeah
correct yeah and uh so
uh people probably walking through from
the market area bars as well
uh but not necessarily
sort of taking any glasses with them i
know
you often find beer glasses and pint
glasses and bottles
dumped around the altering them uh which
is
i suppose it's being a nighttime economy
there it's it's going to happen anywhere
where there's
bars around uh yeah i
i can as i said i can't attribute every
single one of those glasses to toys
that's ridiculous i'm not trying to
attribute that but if there are glasses
that are
within the proximity but of it
like i'm talking down that side of the
causeway which happens
a lot and has happened a lot and has
stopped happening
some of those are from that i i would be
i would bet you all my life they are
some of them
okay thank you okay
does anybody else have any questions for
the residents
i'm i'm okay thank you chair just one
quick question ask uh
you know when you moved into the the
those properties there did the agents
mention anything about the the fact that
they
there may be noise or the you know the
the fact
were you living or was it just sort of
accepted
that is that for both of us
yes i mean it's an estate agent
what more did i say
state agent they said nothing to me when
i moved in but the people that moved in
next door to me were actually told by
the estate agent which was thornley
groves if that's of any
um interest um that totties had actually
been
had its licence revoked and it was not
going to be open again after covered
restrictions
and they moved in in july last year
so i don't know where they got that from
because clearly it was misinformation
they were estate agents like like rob
said they were state agents
yeah so clearly you thought not not
renting
yeah yeah i i owe my property yet
yeah be interested to see what happened
with the planning process but anyway
that's
it's done now isn't it so so uh
i'll be in your flats how many of those
are occupied
they're all occupied all nine of them
all nine are occupied
okay thank you um does anybody else wish
to say anything
before we go in to close session mr
dodge you have any comments to make
about what you've heard
um yeah just sort of to address rob's uh
points quickly um uh obviously we have
the policy there i
tell the door staff um you know under no
circumstances people allowed out
of the bar with any drinks um they
are both in the enclosed area um
however i mean don't get me wrong he is
probably correct that
a glass or two or bottles may come from
our venue
however i would also say where his
cut-through is is the cutthroat people
would be walking through from
um goose green entirety and also
roy's sports bar which was previously
coco lounge
and i would say that a lot of people on
the walk while
changing venues would probably try and
sneak out bottles glasses
uh just a drink on the way there it
could be ditching them on the way into
the club as well which is also an issue
that we don't want the customers doing
but
um yeah we're saying the sort of same
thing
i know what i kind of said to uh abby as
well
uh whereas in future we'll put a much
bigger kind of
um emphasis on that moving forward uh to
assure that
uh i mean anything any of the byproducts
of our club are minimized to an absolute
maximum
um to to ensure that it's a
better quality of life and sleep at them
sort of hours for you guys
um but i will also kind of repeat uh
dylan butts point that obviously you
guys moved in there i'm not sure we've
been lied to you by your estate agents
but
um ultron was a nighttime economy we
have been based there for 15
plus years i know you've been there for
two weeks when you made the complaint to
the zombie
um i just think that in that two weeks
was enough wasn't it really
but okay something can i just come in
again quick chair
on that point i just want to know have
the any of the residents
complain to you directly or to the club
no
to be honest i think a lot of residents
had no idea a bit like rob said that
i i was only aware that we could make a
um
a register our concern because my
neighbor again actually saw
i don't know if it was yourself jonathan
actually attached the documents
to the front of totties and went and
read it and if she hadn't done that
and sort of gone oh i wonder what that
is i wouldn't have known about this at
all
yeah at that time and i know in local
media and all the rest of it but
i'm trying to not look at too much media
at the moment to be honest um
it all just gets a bit much you can't
keep on top of everything but i would
have just
thought as there are local residents
we probably would have had a little a
few more people here had they known i
mean my neighbors also vote to complain
but unfortunately they missed the
deadline
um so their application or their letter
was rejected but
can i can i just mention for the benefit
of residents
that obviously environmental service
environmental the council
is always available to anybody for any
uh
environmental concerns um issues can be
raised with them
um at any time
during the week um while we're always
open or
via email so there are there are ways of
registering without having to go in
front of a licensing committee or
anywhere else there are always council
access for a resident anywhere to raise
any
environmental concerns they have yeah
that's a very good point
if you have any concerns at all at any
time then you can register
with with the council and we will
certainly look at them
okay does any anybody else have anything
to say before we
retire to make our decision please
counselling
um just to go just to point out the uh
request for the for the hours
in a few of the over near my premises
i've put them in the chat so you can see
them but they all they all roughly
finish at that sort of
um weekend area around the source you
know 2
30 3 a.m mark
um around that area that might be
with the area with the because we're
talking about the nighttime economy for
the area
but when it comes to any license the
hours are for the individual premises
and it's for what you hear
um in terms of uh in terms of the
representations that you've heard today
uh and the the measures that are being
proposed
proposed by the african um
rather than these uh rather than the
times
for the other areas but obviously you
can take in your local knowledge as a
counselor
as part of part of your um part of your
decision making
so they're in the chat for you thanks
for that
okay so what proposed to do now
everything's been said we're going to
retire
uh into the breakout room to make our
decision
and then we'll come back in in a few
minutes to
to deliver our verdict okay
alex would you like to put us in the
breakout room